you know I don't think Society has ever
been right I keep saying oh well it was
better you know back in the 60s when men
or men I don't even think men were men
back then either I think the Dynamics
were off and now we sort of try to fix
that and we've sort of gone the wrong
way I'm hoping and I actually am very
positive I do think that like the more
of these conversations that we have the
more you know lockdowns helps people
sort of you know be red pilled or wake
up to what's going on so I hope like we
can create a new Society like a parallel
Society of these free thinkers who who
you know want to sort of go back to the
original way that it should be